sono diventato io perché no no
avete sentito qualcuno
hai visto berlino entrata picchi vediamo
che cosa ha lasciato pighi ha lasciato
la scatola vuota di tutti i nuovi
skifidol food slime quindi sapete cosa
vuol dire questo nuova challenge dovrò
trovare tutti i nuovi skifidol food
flyng sono usciti nuovi skifidol slime
food e serie 4 sono 12 slime tutti
diversi li trovate in edicola in
allegato al magazine e oggi li aprirò
tutti con voi poi alla fine del pd
scrivetemi qual è stato il vostro
preferito
ma iniziamo subito la ricerca via che
c'è merlino lavori pighi e in giardino
eccola bravissimo marino dove sta
andando
se pighi in giardino vuol dire che ha
nascosto degli sly man giardino quindi
andiamo subito a controllare ha nascosto
uno spray mila dietro primo trovato
guardate
c'è qualcosa qua secondo slime trovato
ha trovato un altro club
ok torniamo in casa ciao berlino 6
voluto assegnarmi grazie ho perso una
vita però preso tre slime siamo già al
capitolo 2 sbrighiamo se non mi sono
dimenticato di dirvi lasciate un bel mi
piace qua provatelo essere uniti a
centro 4 secondi 4 3 2 1 tempo scaduto
oggi siete riusciti ma ora sono troppo
curiosa iniziavo ad aprire questi tre
lai un rimo live
facciamola boxing di questa slime g
ovviamente tutti questi slime non si
mangiano sano slime questa si accende
anche al buio prima semina mio vediamo
ci sono il miur se is a mettere nello
slime e poi dentro esistono due slime 1
arancione è uno bianco atria voli questo
è lo slime bianco ed ecco lo slime
arancione andiamo mischiarli anche che
gli orsetti eccolo qua gams live con gli
orsetti secondo slime slime gramsci and
butter vediamo fly mood giallo uno rosso
e delle palline per renderlo un po
crunch con l'aiuto di vidal e abbiamo
realizzato con questo slide were le
finte patatine di sliven questo butters
lime e poi con questo crunchy slime la
salsa
che ora rimettiamo un po di patatine
slime sincero contenitore assieme alla
salsa ed ecco fatto prossimo slime lo
shake it la investe immagino che
s'ispira milkshake e tenta c'è uno slice
rosa e uno bianco vediamo come sono
queste per trasformarlo in un cotton
slime è quella slime rosa e anche
profumatissimo e poi mettiamo un po di
questo bianco che lo trasformerà in
cotto slime guardate qua il mio cotton
live con la cannuccia guardate che
carino ora continuiamo la nostra ricerca
prima che scada il tempo
[Musica]
bye bye di open gates è andata via
prenderò sisma la prima che ritorni
ecco ecco all'altro 3 slime torniamo è
appreso di nuovo pighi siamo al capitolo
2 o 3 ma l'importante è che ho preso
altri tre
[Musica]
vediamo subito come come queste lo slime
g più butter 2 in 1 della polverina che
lo renderà un po trans simoon slime
marroncino batte 3 1 slime gamida da ho
creato una sorta di ciambella green
butterfly gammines line le decorazioni
sopra prossimo slide lo slime mix kawaii
qua abbiamo un flap gelli e un clip lime
ed ecco qua i tre slime questo è il flap
il gelli e questo clean
ho mai visto uno slam così a delle
letterine dentro delle letterine
colorate prossimo slime super carino
l'aims lasci o sgusci ovviamente
ispirato al sushi anche la confezione
appunto quindi avuto come allora abbiamo
quattro tipi di slime questo bianco
crunchy per creare appunto il riso rosso
franci verde battere e klien rota ecco
qua i vitalizi siamo divertiti a provare
a ricreare un po di sekulic carini e ora
la mia parte preferita mischiarli tutti
assieme è uscito ovviamente un verde non
vedo l'ora di mandarli tutti non solo
per me non posso della terra non vedo
l'ora di assaggiare questo bellissimo
[Musica]
progetto non si mangiano solo slime non
si possono mangiare do not lime cosa non
si possono mangiare forte molto bello
questo un ciufolo di è un off line
beh dovevo immaginarmi che vitali ne
avrebbe trovato qualcuno visto che
sembrano cibo che amori subito stupri ma
che programmarli nuovamente guardate
banche non solo tre likely terrestar
time vediamo come abbiamo un slime
bianco e uno slime marroncino glitterato
e clicco a uniti anche questo profuma
tantissimo profuma di biscotti prossimo
slide ufficioso fla vito su questo
ispirato ai cereali adoro anche questa
confezione vediamo qua abbiamo uno slime
trasparente arancione dei cerchietti con
molti è un offline bianco ed eccoli qua
i nostri l'affido proviamo mischiarli
super flat o prossimo slime golden slime
questo è ispirato a un cioccolatino
sicuramente vediamo ed eccolo qua il
nostro slime c'è un slime butter nero e
uno slide giallo glitterato e curico a
me stiamo li vediamo come diventa vari
glitter dorati e anche questo e profuma
tantissimo anche se ho solo una vita
penso di farcela anzi magari chiedo
aiuto a vitale visto che è bravissimo
trovare il cibo un altro slime eccolo
qua era nascosto qua in camera chissà da
quanto tempo
wow non mancano solo due possiamo
farcela magari c'è qualche altro slime
nascosto qua in cameretta in effetti non
ho controllato bene qua
o no che cosa vi aspetta
o no sono diventata miope o no vitale
vitale miri subito quale come farò a
trovare gli ultimi due minuti non sono
davvero pg sono libro special one non
sono finito l'unità non giocare più
parti ma titolo pinti cioè volevo dire
altro vanità non farlo per chi o cosa
stai facendo non voglio farti niente
pagani che cosa è quello ma questo
berlusconi ma non ultimo è mancato lo
devo assolutamente trovarlo per tornare
normale quindi se i picchi sei una vita
giusta serenità sono sono diventata baby
perché quindi mi ha preso a trasformare
l'ultimo dunque magari qui da qualche
parte hai provato a dare un'occhiata in
giro io ho guardato ovunque se magari
pighi l'avesse nascosta nelle sue tasche
gli dice qualcosa qui ecco perché tutto
qualcosa sì io ho trovato degli ebrei
[Musica]
sono tornato normale bossi abbiamo
trovato tutti gli slam zuber slime
skifidol foam più extra crunch in qua
abbiamo uno slime franci rosso live lati
bianco lime gaumy rosso provato a creare
qualcosa ora vado a chiuderlo
che cosa vi ricorda ma ora proviamo ad
aprirlo vediamo se si vede bene
l'interno l'interno c'è lo slime bianco
e lo slime un rosso e dei suv lo slime
crans prossimo drive questo mi
incuriosisce tantissimo perché anche una
sorpresa dentro e lo slide surprise mega
slime marrone battere della polverina
per trasformarlo in un costo di slime è
la sorpresa è che carina una fetta ecco
qua con questo sly muri creato un ovetto
ultimo slime purtroppo il cono slime
questo and butter più snow più super
candy vediamo come uno slide butter
marroncino per fare il cono immagino le
migrazioni da mettere sopra l'aims non
rosa e uno slideshow perde proviamo a
creare il nostro cono per abbiamo
provato più o meno a ricreare il nostro
coro sono sicura che voi sarete più
bravi questi sono i gusti e questo è il
cono e ora proviamo mischiarlo vediamo
come diventa adoro questi due colori dal
gelato mischiato abbiamo creato una
sorta di muffin cupcake e questo era
purtroppo l'ultimo slime vi ricordo che
potete trovare di slime skifidol food
serie 4 in edicola in allegato al
magazine
qual è il vostro preferito scrivetelo
nei commenti
ricordatevi di lasciare o mi piace
ora vi lasciamo qua quattro case linee
su cui cliccare per vedere i nostri
altri video cliccate su quella che
preferite
buona visione ciao